here's your weekend ticket this is the  Oasis it's a place where the limits of  reality are your own imagination a young  hero searches for treasure in ready  player one this is war for control of a  picture I was everything he needed me to  be in agrimony a long-suffering wife  takes action when she is betrayed  I'm Diana robbers fiance save my prayers  for the wedding day the church the  estate campus in the first place  a pastor faces a huge challenge in God's  not dead a light in darkness how do we  actually know that our values are any  more valid than anyone elses see what's  hot in theatres with this week's fantasy  patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]